[Music]  it will come from all over the world to  see this it is a spectacle unlike most  I've ever witnessed this is their gift  [Music]  by the way this was so good it is real  you're like a people working for me my  ideas I'm running the show on the horn  back in on Nagato saddle booth  this right here is the land of  opportunity they play a part  [Music]  / for  have you ever been to Mexico by be  instructed about from the kidnapping  like don't forget that part we thought  natrium  I think anybody who calls me I was  afraid  we're not happy all right  is why I don't like divorce army women  do that in divorces when they get the  children and then the father's never  seen them  [Music]  we are gonna get around  [Applause]  I just want to talk from my heart  here briefly and when I'm here I  and allow myself chance  this is hard for me to control my  passion a very nasty person  it's gonna be the best beloved back  [Music]